On,
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
uh,
match fourth,
2000 [inaudible] 19.
What's going on?
Yeah,
I know I'm really late.
I'm really late.
But yesterday was the first taping my next special,
uh,
at Royal Albert Hall and tonight is the next one.
So yesterday I had a bunch of stuff I had to do,
uh,
for like the intro of the special in all of that type of stuff.
So it went great last night,
had an awesome time and I never take the special world.
I always just did like two shows one night done.
I've never done like a show and then waited a whole day and then do another
show.
So,
uh,
I'm just looking tonight like I could not have been more thrilled with how it
went last night.
Um,
did not have any of this stupid torture that happens afterwards where you're
just like,
Oh God,
I,
why did I do this?
And I that I didn't say that.
Is anybody going to like me after this?
I didn't do any of that shit.
I was just like,
all right,
I miss something here,
Miss,
who gives a fuck,
right?
Yeah,
it's fine.
I don't give a shit.
It's all gonna be good.
So,
um,
tonight I'm just going to go out and have a good time and I'm as excited as I
was to record this special eye.
After last night,
I kind of felt a little bit of sadness of like,
I'm really gonna miss these jokes.
I've never had that feeling before.
Um,
but I know the next ones that come in or whatever,
but it's kind of hitting me here is I'm doing this like,
wow,
this is kind of the end of the run for these jokes,
you know,
and then I just move on like bill Bixby right at the end of the hulk.
Just walk away from the act.
Um,
and the smartest thing I did was I already did a Gig at,
um,
Royal Albert Hall.
Uh,
ah,
for fuck's sake.
Somebody else just come,
hang on,
hang on.
Sorry.
Hit hit.
Pause.
Fucking rang the doorbell and then rings it again.
Like the fucking hotel's on fire.
Oh,
sorry to disturb you.
Just want to know if you need anything in the minibar.
No,
I'm,
I'm good.
Thank you.
Geez.
We assuming I'm not fucking here to fucking rings would if I was sitting here
with my fucking balls hanging out.
You're going to ring it that fast and then you walk in and then let me guess I'm
in trouble.
Right?
Is it true you had your balls out,
sir?
Well,
yes,
I was in that shot up.
There was a woman knocking on that door.
You should have realized that any second someone could come walk again.
Um,
by the way,
is that John Wayne stuff the dumbest thing.
What is this thing now where we're just going to dig up dead people?
It did.
Did you see what they said in 1964?
Well,
I have,
I imagine nothing good.
They fucking got this documentary coming out about Michael Jackson.
It's just like the guy's dead.
Like,
I don't understand.
what the fuck would they every other day now somebody dead.
Somebody got to come along and fucking dig them up and be,
hey,
you know,
they,
I don't know how much you enjoy this music if you know that the person did this.
Okay,
why did they only do it to famous people?
Can all of us dig up our grandparents and be like,
Eh,
remember when you said that
all of these fucking it,
I just don't,
I do not fucking get it.
I don't fucking get it.
Can you believe this?
This fucking guy who was born in 1907 sounded like a guy who was born in 1907
yes.
Yes.
I kid whose grandparents don't go out and say crazy shit.
Okay.
That's the newest bucket thing on earth,
on earth.
A buck and interview from 40 50 years ago and then line it up with today's,
you know what's right?
And you don't have to go back that far.
Go back into somebody's Twitter history member when you said this.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Remember when we were all saying that that's what you supposed to be.
Oh,
you know what,
you mother fucking cock sucking fucking assholes.
What now?
Just going to,
I just want to go to the CDC fucking Bull Shit.
Hello.
You have what?
Miss who?
I don't know who that is.
Bye.
I have Miss Simmie Ms Kimmy,
I don't give a fuck.
That is.
MMM.
Anyways,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
That's like the new fucking thing.
The new fucking thing is to go back at time and just look up.
Hey,
Yay.
Quite evidently Truman Capote's he was,
uh,
he needs,
but again,
two minutes.
We thought he was
just think about someone they just put for all the fucking jokes.
I literally saw somebody get interviewed the other day and they were talking
about the office,
the American version.
And they asked,
could you make that today and the Oh no,
no,
we,
we can never do that.
We,
cause most of those jokes wouldn't work today.
That was 10 fucking years ago.
Yeah.
All right.
So Jesus Christ,
enough with,
with the fucking shock and awe,
that shit.
You're going to dig up somebody who died 40 fucking years ago and they said
something surprising.
MMM.
It's like if you were born in 1907 and somebody interviewed you 40 years ago,
you,
you would not want that interview to be made fucking public.
You wouldn't,
um,
anyways,
what fucking world that we live in that the,
the office now considered too edgy for television.
Oh,
James is,
you could never do,
it wasn't the most absurd fucking shows you have to sign your life.
MMM.
I Dunno,
but that's where we are because,
well,
that's where we are because 8% of the fucking best,
my rough as far as I can tell the people that I talked to,
everybody else is just like,
dude,
what is the big fucking deal?
Yeah.
You know,
it's fucking hilarious.
Someday you're going to sound like you're fucking grandparents.
Someday you're going to be in your fucking seventies.
And something you said in your forties is going to sound fucking ridiculous.
Yeah.
Like nobody's like,
it's nobody's allowed to like I don't,
I don't know.
I don't even,
I don't even fucking,
and I don't understand all of these fucking people that are going on social
media doing this.
It's just,
I won't swear.
[inaudible].
What about you?
If I for anybody gave a fuck about you,
you know,
named cunt and went back into your fucking life,
they can't find somebody to say that you said something that did something.
It's called being a human being.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I told you that shit when I was in Scotland,
that woman lifts dead broke dead fucking article.
It was talking about commemorative statues and she's like,
nothing makes my heart sink.
Like when I hear there's,
they're going to put up a commemorative statue.
It's like nothing.
Yeah,
you fucking a genocide child pornography.
Nothing quite makes you fucking heart drop like the making of a commemorative
statutes.
Oh Jesus.
Um,
okay.
Anyways.
Can you believe Christopher Columbus was actually a fucking asshole?
Okay.
New evidence shows.
It's just like,
where was that new evidence?
What was it just sitting on somebody's desk for fucking 400 years?
MMM.
He's a fat.
All these fucking people compared to what?
Somebody in 2019 yeah.
I would like to think that people learn how to treat other people better each
year.
So what we're supposed to be doing,
you know what I mean?
If you go back and watch an episode of solid gold,
there's a lot of people dancing today that,
uh,
on that day that would get laughed out of the fucking club.
And that was the peak at dancing back then.
But it progressed and now all those moves that were unbelievable and now kind of
basic,
okay,
that's what happened.
So just Kinda,
you know,
can you believe the guy that won the Indy 519 55 wouldn't even rip qualified for
the race in 2019?
I don't think this guy's a champion.
Okay.
I think they need to rethink that championship.
I,
Ben,
we withdraw.
We going 140 miles an hour.
I mean,
the fucking pace guarded,
it goes faster than that.
Yeah.
MMM.
I Dunno.
So it's just eye to eye.
That's
all right.
If it,
does that do anything,
does it really do anything to say,
hey,
this guy who's,
who's been dead for 40 years is,
is actually this now?
Okay,
okay.
So what am I supposed to do now?
Go back and look at this person's sports career or their fucking movie career
and look at them differently somehow and then sit there and look at myself like
I'm this great fucking person just because I had the luxury of being born when I
was born
and then be so fucking full of myself.
Then I'm not looking at this guy being like,
well wait a minute.
Someday I'm going to be dead 40 years.
And then people go back and see the things that I said and am I going to like,
I'm going to survive that.
Um,
all right,
bill,
I think you made your point.
All right.
You know,
a lot of people think Abe Lincoln said,
good guy.
Apparently new evidence shows
he went to a fucking Sadie Hawkins dance and a,
he evidently he was fucking quite rude to his date that night.
Four score it Hashtag four score and seven beers ago.
Drink much.
A boy,
I dunno.
Um,
anyways,
okay.
Whatever.
Uh,
so I got one more.
One more fucking night.
See,
this is what I want to open with tonight.
This is what I want to talk about and get this out of my fucking system.
But I,
I hate the fucking document,
my jokes tonight,
so I want to thank everybody that she came out in Manchester,
Glasgow,
and a Birmingham.
I had a great time and,
uh,
found out that I was not dehydrated.
I actually had a little bit of a stomach virus.
I can't believe it.
What this high quality food that I've been eating here for the last fucking 10
days.
[inaudible]
MMM.
Oh my God.
I,
I just don't know if I'm,
I'm just,
I have to be going to the wrong places,
but what they do to what cheeseburger over here,
it's just like,
as an American,
it's offensive.
I feel like it's,
it's a one of our signature dishes.
Okay.
What we added to the international culinary fucking whatever.
Right.
Sorry.
Let's try to be eloquent there.
Um,
for them to just fucking make it the way that they make it.
I'm not telling me it was just,
there's just something,
there's just something wrong about it.
MMM.
But I keep ordering them in hopes it's almost going to get it right.
Um,
okay.
But anyways,
he had turned out,
I have a a,
I had like a stomach virus now.
I think I'm,
I'm past it.
Um,
so I can give my all to my dick and shit jokes tonight.
Uh,
rest in peace.
Luke Perry,
uh,
Jesus Christ.
52 fucking years old with kids.
Yeah,
that's a scary one man.
And then the guy weighed like 130 pounds and I felt okay.
Okay.
And um,
so now I'm on the Internet and I'm trying to fucking,
you know,
early signs
of a stroke and how you can screen for it and yeah,
you can do this to screen forward,
but don't do it too many times because the scan isn't good for Ya.
And it's just like,
so they had the,
uh,
all these lists here,
like the top causes.
This is for all old men like me.
All right,
you ready?
Go.
Top causes for stroke.
All right,
here we go.
Come on hotel.
Right is a hypertension high blood pressure.
I was site when the doctor came and took my blood pressure,
said I have the blood pressure,
but 25 year old,
he goes,
do you work out a lot?
And I said,
I do work out a lot.
High cholesterol.
I don't have that,
uh,
diabetes.
I don't have that central obesity.
That means having a belly.
I don't have that smoking.
I do that.
So that's the one I got to get out because I'm not living for myself anymore.
I live in for the Kiddos.
So,
and I've come to this,
this,
this realization
of a,
of my,
and I finally figured it out.
I figured out what kind of drinking drink or I am,
why it's gone off the rails.
While all of a sudden it became this guy that needed to take breaks.
And um,
yeah,
the big thing that I,
how I fucked up was I brought it into the house.
All right.
And if I could give anybody any young man,
young woman out there,
fucking a yell and fucking transferring a humanoid,
whatever the fuck you supposed to say.
One of those tr words.
All right.
Yeah.
Listen to this little clip and 40 years.
Okay.
We'll see if they take it down my fucking monument at the innovators of
podcasting and the filthy wink at the podcast museum.
Right.
See if they don't want to take down my fucking golden statue with the fucking
orange leaflet over my balls.
Um,
okay.
You don't want to bring your vices home with you.
Okay.
You want to have to go out and get them.
All right.
So,
uh,
the where I fucked up his,
I,
I ended up having a booze collection at home and because I was buying some
higher end stuff,
you start to think,
oh well I'll make a collector.
I'm a connoisseur.
No,
dude,
you're a fucking booze hound.
So,
um,
I'm just gradually just given bottles away.
I got some Pappy van Winkle,
I'm not giving that away,
you know,
but I have some,
a couple nicer bottles of things that cost me whatever,
80 a hundred bucks or but like to be,
um,
I saw my kids see my drinking.
Okay.
Obviously my kid can listen to the podcast,
know what I was,
but like I,
so I don't want to be doing that.
I don't want to be smoking cigars in front of her.
I don't be drinking fucking booze,
none of that shit.
She asked me about it.
I'll tell her what I did,
I'll be honest with them and then tell how eh,
how fucking stupid it was,
how much time I wasted and all that type of shit.
You know,
I did have a good time,
you know,
whatever.
But anyways,
I just added some think it's a good look.
You'd be sitting at home fucking uh,
yeah,
boots.
And
not that I've ever done that in front of the right way to,
she goes to sleep.
But there's been nights where I'm just like,
wow dude,
I am like you.
Like,
you know,
rolling the dice here.
Cause God forbid I'm down here legally fucking hammered.
And what if my wife had some sort of medical issue?
Now I'm drunk,
I got to get my kid and my wife's,
now I have,
what do I do here?
I got to fucking call an Uber.
And all of this shit because I'm too drunk to drive.
Or you might just call the fucking ambulance.
I'm going to be standing there fucking hammered as somebody chest.
Not a good luck.
That's not stress.
That's something a dad does,
but not the dad that I want to be.
So I'm getting the shit out of my house.
Uh,
I've decided I'm taking the year off and then next year I'll see what I want to
do,
but if there's anything that I want to do,
I'm going to have to go out and go get it.
Um,
and that goes for the cigars too.
okay.
I'm,
I'm going to drastically cut that down and um,
I don't know.
But then I remember hearing this quote that said,
beware of the man with no vice or something like that.
Uh,
okay
man.
With no vice.
Yeah.
Saying
let's see what it is.
What is this thing?
Show me a man.
Here we go.
Show me a man without vice.
Uh,
where is it?
Show me a man without vice and I'll show you one without virtue.
No,
that doesn't,
that just sound like some dumb shit.
A drunk would say at a bar.
Okay.
Uh,
well he does in Jay's fucking doing something.
Um,
okay,
so the man,
let's see something here.
Vices,
vice quotes.
I actually,
I don't understand that.
It's like,
so if you live like a vizsla life,
then you have no virtue.
What is a virtue?
What is the actual definition?
So on virtuous behavior is showing high moral standards.
So if you,
if you don't have any low moral standards,
you won't have any high moral standards.
So if,
if you're not fucking blowing a couple of rails,
that means you're not going to help a fucking old lady across the street.
Can't you be the guy who's not doing blow,
not boozing,
eating,
you know,
in a healthy way and being a family man and,
and also be a good person.
I don't understand that.
You know,
is it because if you meet somebody that's strong enough,
is this just insecurity by bucking people that have vices?
Um,
cause I gotta be honest with a,
via [inaudible].
If I can get rid of,
if I don't bows and I didn't smoke cigars,
I think that's it.
That mass,
what I do,
I drink and smoke.
Yeah.
So now I'm not drinking.
Since I've been over here,
I've had one cigar.
Okay.
You know,
I barely smoke.
If I get rid of that,
you know,
then what?
Jesus Christ.
Well then the bill,
you have the most boring fucking podcast in the history of podcasting,
I guess.
MMM.
I Dunno.
I,
I got it.
I'll figure it out though.
But I,
I don't want to be this guy just like,
you know,
I never have a drink or I never have a cigar.
I just gotta get it out of my fucking house.
All right.
I feel like invited a vampire and you know,
like I'm in the lost boys except with booze and cigars.
Um,
sort of,
I'll do that.
Then I'll just sit there and judge my wife every time she has a rosy,
nice,
nice example that you're setting.
Um,
I gotta be honest with you,
London,
I'm loving it.
You know,
I was never really a London guy was more Paris gay.
I don't know what happened.
Now I'm starting to like London a little better.
You know,
despite the fucking food,
Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ at the detail,
the amount of places that they conquered with all these spices in know,
I always heard that they brought them back.
I could,
God knows they're not fucking used them.
I tend to be,
I don't know where to go.
You know,
they've got too many fucking celebrities out here.
All the spice girls does spice girls.
Right?
Where do they eat these?
No Way.
They put up with this food.
There's no way.
I know last time I came here,
I went to this Indian restaurant that was fucking unbelievable.
And I also went to the ivy the other night and I had the best shepherds five
overhead.
Um,
so it hasn't been all bad,
but I'll just tell him,
oof.
Everything else I've gone to marriage.
It's like comedy club,
Green Room Bad.
Um,
all right.
But we get it.
You don't like the fucking food?
I,
I'm sorry.
So what's going on in the world of America?
I miss the good old USA.
Let's see what,
when I want to go to search you s a news.
Let's see what happens.
President Donald Trump's serves fast food to another title team.
Yeah.
This is how broke we are after fucking these wars.
Why does he keep doing that?
Does he do this to anybody else?
Let's see.
President Donald Trump,
the service food to another title team,
North Dakota State now the championship football team.
Okay.
Oh,
you know what?
This is North Dakota state and there's a lot of white guys on there.
He's still giving them fast food.
Yeah,
I'd love to eat McDonald's in the White House.
It's kind of fucking cool.
Trump welcomed the football championships,
subdivision champions,
the North Dakota State Bison.
You get him some bison burgers there to the White House on Monday and according
to a pool report,
he served them a lunchtime spread,
a big Mac chick filet sandwiches and French fries among other fast food items.
Trumps served a similar meal to the Clemson Tigers while they visited the White
House in January.
According to the pool report,
Trump told the biases that he couldn't serve them a meal prepared by the chef.
But I know you people,
several players laughed.
Yeah.
Oh,
that he could have served them a meal prepared by the chef.
But I know you people,
several players laughed according to the pool report.
A Trump said in January that he personally paid for Clemson's White House faced
to face now because it's visit came in the middle of a partial government
shutdown.
Okay.
Is this,
yeah.
Maybe it's just him trying to be cool.
Yeah.
You know,
did he go to college to Trump even go to college?
It's amazing how little I know about this guy,
Donald Trump.
What's,
see where the fuck he went.
Okay.
He probably went to college where his dad went to college
and that's why there's a legacy here.
He was one of the greatest students ever of this university.
Yeah.
Oh,
of course.
This isn't going to show up.
I have no idea how.
Let me get to the,
uh,
let me read a little bit of advertising as this fucking thing comes together
here.
Yeah.
All right.
Oh,
here we go.
Eh,
we go,
here we go.
Hi honey.
You ever want to buy something online?
Only to find out later.
You missed a discount.
[inaudible] is a free browser.
Add on that signs me the best deals online.
The APP magically auto replies the best deal to my cart and checkout.
Oh,
Harney finds discounts and coupons across 37,000 sites.
Amazon,
Sephora,
Bestbuy,
Nordstrom,
and more.
Shop like normal.
Um,
uh,
honey handles the rest.
Honey has saved it's 10 million members in average of $28 and 61 cents overall
or,
oh,
so it saved $280,661,000.
I don't know.
Fucking,
how do you remember how many members have already saved more than $800 million?
Hey,
it,
thank you for helping me out there.
Well that doesn't make sense.
10 million members.
Okay.
Let's say,
Oh my God.
With the fucking,
the fucking Goddamn fucking,
yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Hang on a second.
Who's this?
Hello?
Finished.
Yeah,
but I'm just recording something.
I'll,
I'll do it.
Yeah.
Yup.
All right,
thank you.
It just can't get the fucking food.
Audi are fast and they want to get rid of the evidence.
All right.
Um,
I swear to God,
nobody has knocked.
I phoned the whole fucking time for second.
They turn on the recorder.
Just seeing,
does this,
does the rug feelokay under the feet?
Um,
where it was they honi
members have already saved 800 or more than $800 million.
Not Bad for something that's completely free and takes just two clicks to
install.
This is fucking free.
Honey has over a hundred thousand five star reviews on Google chrome on the
Google chrome store.
Time magazine calls honey.
Basically free money.
Look,
there's no reason to use honey not to use honey.
It's free to use and easy to install on your computer and just two clicks.
So shop with confidence.
Get Ani for free and join [inaudible] dot com slash bird that's join
honey.com/bur bur are horny.
This smart shopping assistant that saves you time and money when you're shopping
online.
Oh look,
everybody,
it's hymns.
Him.
66% of men start to lose a hair by the age of 35.
Hey,
uh,
once you've noticed thinning hair,
it can be too late.
Is that hairline slew really starting to move backwards?
Any bald spots yet?
Is Your Dick still working?
Uh,
the best way to prevent more hair losses,
to do something about it while you still have some,
it's time to get a handle on those precious locks.
I ask you,
do you want a bald spot to pop up on your hair or your hairline to recede or do
you want to do something about it first?
Why?
Why did guys turn to weird solutions or nothing at all?
Well,
hey,
maybe I just accepted.
Why do you have to pick on me hymns?
Uh,
why did they do that?
Do this when they can turn to medicine and science.
While a lot of them had bad fucking side effects,
you know,
early on,
hey man,
I'm just a podcast listener.
I don't need to be attacked here.
Our it solution for hymns.com at one stop shop for hair loss,
skincare,
sexual wellness for for men,
thanks to science baldness can be optional.
Hims is,
how weird am I going to look when I get older?
Because everybody's going to opt for this shit.
They're just going to get him to keep their fucking hair and then kids run
around when I'm 60 kids will start whispering.
I smattered with that man.
Did he use to be the strong man at the circus?
Uh,
why do guys to Tokyo though for hymns?
Okay,
thanks to science bald.
This could be an option to hims is helping guys be the best version of
themselves with licensed physicians and Fda approved products to help treat hair
loss.
Prescription solutions backed by science.
Hymns was created by guys who know by a guy who knows.
Some men's health conversations are easier online than in person.
Might.
Well Dude,
you're going bald.
Everyone can see it.
You've got to try and hide it.
My listeners can get started with hims complete hair kit for just $5 right now
while supplies last and subjects of doctor's approval restrictions apply.
See website for full details.
Go to for hymns,
H I m s.com/bird.
That's f o r a h I m s.com/burr for hims.com/burr are right.
Oh everybody.
Look Legal Zoom,
legal,
zoom,
um,
five business,
five things business owners can count on from legal zoom numeral Raul.
Oh No.
Ah,
uh,
reliability.
Over 2 million people have used legal zoom to start their businesses.
Llcs as Corp's nonprofits dbhs and more.
You can use legal zoom to get started the right way.
Number two,
Numero dos.
The experience I'm counting right now in three different languages.
If you're not keeping up,
they've been helping all types of business owners for over 17 years.
You can count on legal zoom to help with all the details.
Uh,
numero uno,
dos,
tres,
numero tres,
the trois one tote tray,
helpful support.
They have the right people standing by ready for your questions.
All based in theU s quatro cat
legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is,
isn't a law firm,
but they have a network of independent attorneys licensed in all 50 states.
Can I say 15?
All different language sank home 50.
Uh,
I don't know how to say it in Latino,
whatever I'm fuck.
I'm supposed to say in,
in Latin Spanish.
We don't speak Spanish and that I didn't get the fucking book.
All right.
Sorry.
All they did was teach me about the pilgrims.
Uh,
they can revert review contracts with employment law,
with employment laws,
and I can't even read today and advise you on many of the hurdles that pop up
when you're running a business.
And finally,
number five,
uno.
Dos Tres quatro.
Cinco sank five.
Um,
no surprises.
Legal Zoom provides complete transparency,
transparency with upfront pricing,
customer and a satisfaction guarantee.
Checkout legal zoom today to see how they can make life better for you and your
business.
And don't forget to enter Burr at checkout to save even more legal zoom where
life meets legal,
legal zoom.com.
All right,
who else we got here?
Oh,
policy genius.
Yeah.
Policy.
G L I got all this is the last one.
Thank Christ.
All right.
Policy genius.
Getting life insurance can feel like assembling the world's worst jigsaw puzzle.
How old was somebody who fucking wrote this copy?
Getting life insurance can feel like starting there.
No fucking crank start forward.
Okay.
No matter how much you blow the horn.
Yeah.
MMM.
It can feel like biting down on a bow and arrow while someone digs a slug out of
your calf.
Uh,
it's confusing.
It takes forever.
And when you're finally done,
it doesn't even look cool.
But if you have a mortgage,
kids or anyone who's depending on your income,
it's a puzzle you need to solve.
And policy genius can help you do it.
Policy Genius is the easy way to get life insurance.
It's just two minutes.
In just two minutes.
You can compare quotes from top insurers to find the best policy for you when
you apply online.
The advisors at policy genius will handle all the red tape,
dill,
even negotiate your rate with the insurance company.
No commission sales agents,
no hidden fees,
just helpful advice and personalized services and policy genius.
Does it make life insurance easy?
Uh,
it doesn't just make life insurance easy.
They also make it easy.
Uh,
find the right home insurance,
your auto insurance or disability insurance.
Uh,
they're your one stop shop for financial protection.
So if you find life insurance puzzling,
head to policy,
genius.com and two minutes,
you can prepare quotes,
find the right policy and save up to 40% doing it.
Policy Genius,
the easy way to compare and buy life insurance.
All right.
And with that,
let's see if Donald Trump's Wikipedia page came up.
It did.
He was born June 14th,
Gemini 1946.
Uh,
he's,
the current president is born and raised in New York borough of Queens.
He got an economics degree from the Wharton School.
That's a good one.
Yeah,
I know.
That's a good ones.
I've never really heard of it,
which means it's a high end.
One
was not on my radar to be applied to.
He was appointed president of his family's real estate business in 1971.
Look at that.
He was only 25 years old and he took on that level of responsibility.
Everybody else gets to go out to a fucking bar and drank,
you know,
okay.
Sing some Karaoke.
And he had to take over the family's real estate business.
See everybody thinks these rich kids have it easy.
You know,
you poor kids have no idea how lucky you are to be 25 and none of the pressures
of a real estate company to take over the company built or renovated skyscraper
skyscrapers,
the hotels,
casinos and golf courses.
Trump later stated,
various sites start at various side ventures including licensing his name for
real estate and consumer products.
Yeah,
that's the genius.
That's why when everybody's like giving the finger to a Trump hotel,
it's like it's not really his hotel.
Um,
early life education.
The conflicts of interest.
I mean this,
this is all here,
dude.
This is all what usually you have on a rich guys Wikipedia page.
All right,
let's get to the questions cause I got fucking special to tape here tonight.
Um,
okay.
All right.
What's the first question?
Soccer playoffs.
All right,
so I mentioned,
I was saying how weird it is that they don't have a play off play off in the
premier league and how huge that would be.
So evidently this person's going to set me straight as to why they don't do it.
Bill,
they don't have,
they don't have soccer.
Yeah.
In playoffs they don't play offs and soccer's with the person metric,
but they happened to have various cup competitions that add a different dynamic
to the mix.
When you think about,
think about it,
it's extremely stupid to have playoffs in the first place.
Why would the most consistent and best team to top a table in any sport over the
duration of a season not get recognized as the best team?
Well,
easily.
Well that's easy.
While in our world,
you know,
you have people just the way shit lines up who's in your division,
you end up playing a tougher schedule than somebody else.
Yeah.
You know,
and it also depends like when you play somebody,
if their best player was hurt and then the other team comes to play him and that
guy's player is back.
You know what I mean?
All of a sudden,
you know,
it's so just like you play a whole season and somebody one point behind you.
Okay.
You're the champion in there that I don't know.
I like playoffs.
And then also playoffs ads like this pressure.
Okay.
Where's the team that's supposed to,
when all of a sudden feels this pressure and then they could choke and you have
great stories.
Okay.
There's plenty of reasons to have playoffs.
Um,
so I don't think it's stupid.
This extremely stupid.
Well then why do you have the World Cup?
Isn't that stupid?
Isn't that a giant fucking planetary fucking playoff?
Why isn't everybody just fucking stay home?
Um,
anyways,
I don't understand this.
Well,
that's a cup competition.
That's a different thing.
So you're,
you're,
you're in the playoffs.
As long as it's a cup,
it's extremely stupid.
Okay.
I don't think it has.
Anyway.
Hockey is the only sport.
Yeah.
Uh,
where I
understand respect the league structure because the Stanley Cup is arguably the
most difficult tropey to win.
All right?
You're all over the map here,
sir.
You can maybe get away with half ass thing in the regular season to clinch
playoffs,
but you have a long way to go to hoist the cup.
Uh,
they actually have a playoff format.
And in the English championship,
which is the League right below the Premier League,
uh,
first and second in the table,
automatically advanced to the premier league while third to six have a two leg
matchup to get an a final for that third promotion spot.
Oh,
that's cool.
So that's where you play off,
sir.
It's very exciting because there are millions of millions of dollars on the line
with that final game playoff.
All right,
so now you like playoffs.
Also offside is when the attacking player is passed the final defender at the
point the ball is played.
If you didn't have this in place,
players would just cherry pick,
get uh,
all game.
And the beautiful game would be a shit show.
Rat Fest.
Uh,
come back to
Niagara.
Canada,
take care.
Um,
I get that shit that you can't just hang.
But my thing is is if somebody is going to run past you,
yeah,
they're not just cherry pick and hanging down the other end of the field.
If somebody is going to run fast to you and they're faster,
you can just slow down and make them off sides.
That's fucking stupid.
That guys fast and then you,
we beat you.
That's my problem.
I'm not saying that,
you know.
Okay.
You know,
look in hockey they have an off sides line.
You've got to clear the fucking zone when the puck comes out.
But like if somebody blows past you with the park,
they don't have to fucking wait to you get into the zone.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
Sorry.
I know it sounds like I'm drinking.
I'm just drinking a giant bottle of water,
glass bottle.
Um,
fancy man as Jim Norton likes to say.
all right,
well I get that sir.
I don't think,
I actually think that you actually enjoy playoffs.
Um,
but you also enjoy the premiere league.
So now you have to say that it's extremely stupid.
And of course,
because you're from Canada,
you get it in the hockey.
You understand those playoffs.
All right,
sending food back.
this is what I wanted to hear from people,
how you go about it.
And he says,
I'm a 28 year old male living amongst you and all the other narcissistic
transplant concept decided they were too good for their hometowns and needed to
move to this coastal Eden that we call Los Angeles and attempt to achieve a
dream of creating career.
Doing what I love.
Parentheses creating slash playing music.
Uh,
well,
sorry.
If you wanted to play music for a living,
you know,
you probably would eventually moved to Los Angeles to get more in the mix or
Nashville,
don't you move where the industry is?
Um,
at any rate,
mmm.
I guess he's,
he's to be joking that,
that Los Angeles is an Eden.
It's not an Eden.
You had to steal water to try and turn it into a fucking Eden.
It's a shit show that shouldn't be there.
But it is.
And what we've done with it is,
is amazing.
I mean,
am I saying we now with Los Angeles,
I've had been there that long.
Um,
at any rate being a musician,
I worked a number of side gigs including waiting tables.
I've waited tables at cheap joints as well as fine dining establishment.
It's like award winning chef dudes.
Oh,
I think this guy was being sarcastic about uh,
yeah,
la.
Yeah.
Um,
anyways,
at any rate,
uh,
I think I can set you straight on sending food back basically.
And maybe obviously the cheaper the restaurant,
the riskier it is to send your food back.
Great Point.
Uh,
when I work fine dining,
you're primarily in a restaurant with a kitchen is actually open to the public.
So sending food back is handled in front of the clientele and that's would never
be subjected to being fucked with another great point.
Uh,
that being said,
as you go down in price,
typically not always,
your kitchen is getting a little,
little bit more hidden.
You're employees are probably making less and on top of that,
they're probably always,
again,
not always because I realize some cheaper restaurants are amazing quality,
et Cetera,
not as passionate about what they're doing.
In that case,
your food will possibly get fucked with.
Okay,
here's another person.
Okay.
Uh,
hey Billy,
sugar,
tits.
Um,
okay.
Never worry about sending food back with social media today.
Any decent restaurant would rather you tell them then tell the world that that a
meal was poor.
If a dick.
Yeah.
If a Dick Ed works in the kitchen.
What if a dick,
he d like the name Ed of a Dick.
Ed Works in the kitchen for Dick head.
Oh,
this person was texting and I guess there's some sort of weird,
you get the capital thing in a space button.
If at Dick had works in the kitchen,
who's going to spit in your food?
You can guarantee the kitchen's a Shithole anyways.
Yeah.
See you at Royal Albert Hall on Monday.
Wait a minute.
Yeah,
never worry about sending food back.
And then you end it with,
if a Dick had works in the kitchen,
is gonna spit in your food?
You can guarantee the kitchen's a Shithole anyways.
Meaning it doesn't make a difference cause what's already in the food.
I don't know about that.
All right.
It's not making me feel better.
Formula e a Billy burnout.
Uh,
you mentioned on a recent podcast that the sports low between football and the
start of Formula One,
uh,
March madness,
NBA players,
et Cetera,
has you as you down,
have you tried to watch formula e to fill the gap?
I'm watching for the first time machine year and it's been great.
I got the hiccups now.
This is the all electric racing series.
It's real easy to get up to date since the races or time to have a maximum
length of 45 minutes plus one lap.
Um,
the first four races this season are all up on youtube and there they are
carried live on Spock's Fox sports two in the U s there is no team or set of
teams that dominate like in Formula One and there's been passing Galore in every
race.
All right.
I like this including a photo finish and the last race.
So it's not about getting to the first corner and blocking for the rest of the
race.
There are no pit stops,
but the team still have to strategize to conserve energy.
So they don't run out of power.
Sure.
The cars don't go as fast,
but the competition makes more,
uh,
more than makes up for it.
In my opinion.
Bonus is in the last two races of the seas.
Seasons will be held back to back days in New York City in July.
Oh Shit.
I might be in New York in July chairs and go fuck yourself.
Well eventually I feel like those cars will be faster than the Formula One cars
because I'm just looking at how regular cars are in the street.
You know what I mean?
Like they can make like what a Tesla is shaped like the fact that zero to 60 can
beat a fucking Lamborghini.
Um,
I would think that if you applied that same shit to like a race car and
absolutely no weight other than the battery,
all it comes down to is it,
is it,
the battery is going to be later than the fucking engine.
Um,
and then you don't have all that bullshit under the car where air can get caught
because you can just have that smooth fucking thing like they do underneath the
Tesla.
I Dunno.
I would think that the cars are going to get faster.
Right?
I don't know.
I do think it's funny that people that aren't a gas combustion engines will
think it's funny that they can only run them for 45 minutes and ignore the fact
that the gas combustion engines also,
I have to pull over and get gas.
You know,
it's also not a limitless energy source.
What you got to have is you got to have solar power against somebody with a
giant fucking solar panel duct taped to their fucking head,
all right,
and a giant magnifying glass above it.
The driver dies every race,
but there's no pit stops and can still go 500 miles.
That's how I would do it.
All right,
baby name.
He just get people on death row to drive,
so then also they won't give a fuck.
You know,
if if this space and not to go into the corner,
it'll be really fucking excited.
He had death row inmates with a fucking satellite,
not a satellite of fucking what he'd done a strobe,
I just said it.
Solar panel on their head with a giant magnifying glass.
All right?
Right before they get in the car there,
eat their lead,
their last meal,
whatever it is,
you know,
a little bit of hog and dose,
the turn up and some fucking chicken,
whatever the fuck it is they want,
you know,
and you'd get them in there and that's it.
It's like,
all right,
and here's the thing,
if you win,
whoever wins doesn't get killed.
Wait,
no,
because you'd already died.
Oh,
they got it.
Yet somehow like if you,
if you win,
it's like the dirty dozen.
If you win,
like they let you back out on the street,
Kellen,
back on the street,
the fucking murderers.
I,
no,
it's gotta be something you can do.
I don't know what,
again,
I does the heat.
I don't have it all worked out.
All right,
baby named negotiation strategy bell,
my wife and our and,
and I are having our first baby.
Congratulations.
So baby girl.
Oh,
you hit the lottery and we couldn't be happier.
Happier.
The only issue is picking her name and negotiations are deadlocked.
Here's the negotiation positions.
All right.
I'm going to tell you this before I go any further,
okay.
All right.
Never tell your daughter about this,
okay.
All right.
Whatever her name is,
that's her name.
If you lose all your wife loses on the debate,
do not fucking bring that up to your kid.
Whatever their name is.
The name.
All right.
My wife's tastes.
The names could be best described as somewhere between Hollywood diva and in
1960s,
flower child.
Oh my God.
Thank names like apple and moon beam.
Uh,
Layla like the Eric Clapton Song is their best idea to date,
but it wouldn't be my first choice.
No,
that song's too popular.
Um,
I dunno.
Waitlists not bad.
I don't know.
Okay.
I would like to get my grandmother's name.
For me.
Co and old Japanese name somewhere.
That's got to be a middle name dude.
Yeah,
anywhere.
My daughter's name,
she died before I was born and it would really mean a lot to me and my side of
the family to get that even as a middle of the eye.
That's a middle name too.
My wife doesn't like the name fool me Co
uh,
specifically she doesn't like the way it sounds and thinks it sounds too close
to the word Fumar which you as a scholar of French,
no.
Is the verb to smoke as into smoke.
Uh Oh.
Uh,
in French.
No,
I knew a rocket was something like that.
Um,
I am basically willing to concede the first name to get full Mikko as a middle
name.
Well that's cool because if the kids like half Japanese,
I don't know if you guys are full Japanese.
That's cool.
So you get the little bit of that in there and the name.
A lot of people do that.
Um,
anyways,
he said,
but I haven't gotten much headway in negotiation.
Again,
I am willing to concede that the first name be something kind of weird to get my
grandmother's name,
which is admittedly unusual but highly meaningful at as the middle name.
I have two questions.
Sorry.
First of all,
if your wife is going to go all hippy trippy dippy
and then you know,
you can't be like fucking,
yeah,
like wheat grass shots for me.
Coach Johnson.
Do you can't have that?
I would think.
Oh man,
this is tough because I have to question how did you,
when the lovely new Nia go about picking your daughter's name,
what is my path to getting my wife to agree to Fomoco for me call as my
daughter's middle name.
MMM.
I think,
I think you guys need to stop thinking about ourselves and think about your
daughter.
Okay.
As she's going to have to be this name.
Somebody is going to have to say this name and she's going to have to be like,
yes.
Present.
Okay.
So
yeah,
I would just say to my wife like,
listen,
all right.
Okay.
I'm willing to concede for me all.
Alright.
But where she's not going to have some hippy,
trippy fucking
fucking
white celebrity kid fucking name.
Can't have that.
Yeah.
You're not naming this kid after an emotion or a fucking fruit or vegetable.
Okay.
It's just a fucking assets.
Just a fucking asshole thing to do to your kid.
Okay.
It's so fucking self involved and it's so just like,
oh,
look at me,
look how creative I am.
It's just like,
don't,
don't you remember going to school,
don't you remember those,
those first brutal years,
if there was anything even remotely different about you,
you were going to get the shit kicked out of you.
It's going to happen anyways.
Why help the other kids out?
Why
the kids going to hate the fucking name?
Okay.
Um,
anyways,
so I would be thinking about the kid.
I wouldn't be thinking about my own family and all of that type of shit.
Just get the kid a fucking cool name.
That sounds good,
but the last name and just let your kid be who they want to fucking be.
All right.
And don't force your fucking agenda on them from day one with some fucked up God
damn name.
That's my 2 cents.
All right?
Okay.
Um,
all right.
Lady asked me to not Burp at the gym.
Okay.
Uh,
hey Bilbo saggy baggy jeans.
I was at the gym the other day.
Okay.
Uh,
in my building trying to get back in shape for this summer as I've been at Booz
bag getting through this fucking winter.
Anyways,
I was on the elliptical,
a nice brisk pace.
Um,
okay.
Hundred and 85 Rpm is Jesus Christ and was listening to your podcasts actually.
And there was one other woman on a treadmill,
three treadmills away,
uh,
walking at a slight incline.
Okay.
And I'm guessing a speed of 2.3 and reading a novel.
Oh yeah.
That's not working out.
Uh,
my family has acid reflux.
So sometimes at the gym when I'm really pushing it,
I would
okay.
Inherently,
lightly burp every few minutes.
At about 25 minutes into my session,
I hear something coming from my head phones and this late fifties,
wish lady is waving at,
okay.
Me Out of my periphery.
I looked over at her and move my earpiece away to hear and she said nicely,
could you please not burp anymore?
It's distracting me.
Well Dude,
if you fucking belching while running 185,
I mean,
it sounds like you're flying.
Just run a Bra.
Uh,
I mean,
what are you doing?
You're in public.
Um,
anyway,
Bill,
the amount of rage I was filled with for such an insane requests was
unfathomable.
Well.
How loud were you burping?
You had your headphones on?
She put up with it for 20 fucking minutes.
He said,
I thought about going to apologize to her,
asking her name and giving her a fake name from myself and then telling the
leasing off,
see office,
what a [inaudible] this lady was.
What is with you young people just wanting to tell on each other.
Did you want to make a video of it and then fucking uploaded?
I just thought you guys are all just trying to get each other in trouble and
kicked out of things.
The fucking rat generation.
Uh,
I refrain,
finish my workout and continued on with my day.
My question for you is one,
am I just,
uh,
being completely,
am I just in just being completely flabbergasted by a lady walking on a
treadmill,
reading a book,
telling me not to Burp when I have.
Okay.
Gerd,
Two,
what,
what have you done in that situation to do?
First of all,
you know,
how the fuck does she know that you have acid fucking reflux and stop acting
like you have leukemia?
You know what I mean?
This is this right here.
This is what's wrong with,
with with what social media did to the individual.
You're in a public gym,
you're belching.
No one wants to listen to your fucking bourbon and you're a boozy fat fuck
because of the winter.
I respect the fact you're trying to lose the weight.
You know?
Maybe if you ate better,
you wouldn't have these.
This will fuck wants to sit and listen to you burp and it gives a fuck.
She's over there walk and a half a mile,
an hour with the book.
That's her loss.
She's not really working,
but she waited for fucking 20 minutes.
Feed a belt should out of your system and you didn't.
It's fucking gross.
No.
Okay.
I would take,
I need a pack of fucking Rolaids and go for a walk around the block,
but I mean you,
you can't be like belching in public and then try and turn around and make
yourself the victim because you got acid reflux.
You know
what if she was really gassy and was just farting the entire time?
Okay,
yeah.
She says,
okay,
I am irritable bowel syndrome.
Well,
fucking,
you know,
go drink some of that pink shit and fucking go for a walk.
Okay.
They'll come in here and close the Goddamn door.
Yeah.
You're fucking gassy horror.
I don't know.
I don't want to tell you
I,
I'd say,
yeah,
you're in the wrong there,
sir.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
no one wants to go to the gym.
Listen to burping going 90 miles an hour and a fucking elliptical.
Okay.
And I don't,
I don't care about your acid reflux and how it affects you as a person.
Um,
I think you need to take that into consideration.
You know,
why don't you just go get one of those TRX bands and just work out in the house?
We can easily go for a walk.
Okay.
You know,
it's better for the environment,
all the energy,
then an elliptical users.
Let's go walk up the hill.
He can fucking Burp to your heart's content.
Then you're not bugging her.
And she could sit there and fucking slowly walk to her grave while she reads the
next Harry Potter
fucking novel.
Right.
Does that work?
Just didn't work for everybody.
I hope it does.
Um,
all right.
I am going to have to pull up a little bit short here.
MMM.
I apologize.
I just have to,
I gotta tape this fucking thing tonight and then I'll be back in the states.
Might be a little jet lag.
I know these last couple of ones,
I've been a little fucking scatterbrain and jetlag that just been working a
little too hard,
but you know,
after tonight I'm on the other side of it and,
uh,
hopefully I'll go back to,
I'm not being as scatterbrained,
just the normal level of scatter brain ish shit that I say.
All right.
That is it.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on Thursday and thank you from the bottom,
my heart,
everybody that showed up on this run through,
uh,
the UK.
I've been having a great time.
All right,
that is it.
I'll see you Thursday.